amazing footage came out today of Trump
getting off Air Force One and putting
his hand out to Melania and she swaps it
she's well actually we have I think we
have the footage but I just want to get
your take he puts his hand out and she's
like get away from me it's so
interesting because huh
you touch me but it's such a curious
thing because you're wondering I'm
wondering he's gonna get obsessed with
the fact that people are talking about
that video and he's gonna feel the need
to respond isn't he yeah and he's he
going to say no she didn't swipe my
hands away and he's gonna add but I
don't know what you say about that
moment when it's so clear to all of us
who've been in a long relationship what
that moment means most people would say
that's the person I love we had a little
tiff and so what it's not a big deal but
he'll say it so it's a fake mediate by
the way yeah yeah but he'll say it's a
thank you he'll say it's that it's the
fake media and you know there goes my
skateboard and they'll they always get
it wrong right no right I'm looking
forward to a crazy if he has a
convoluted explanation for what happened
he like she was saving my life because
that just then a knife was thrown and
she batted in it but the press took the
knife out of the picture they were like
there's gonna be some crazy thing she
saved my life there was a bug on my hand
and she was swatting it away from me I
didn't get you know she was reminding me
I'm a germaphobe she saw the Ebola virus
headed towards me
you